And you're supposed to believe there's a bunch
of 12-year-old, I think, Canadian kids sitting
around a campfire being like, "And then, she
died." Like what? No, no, that show is-
They're all like, "What's the story all aboot,
eh?"
Right. Exactly. "Ooh, sorry for scaring you."
We just lost all our Canadian viewers.
Nina, what are some of the disturbingly dark
kids franchises that scarred you for life?
So as a child of the Nineties, there was really
only one option for me to pick, and it was
Are You Afraid of the Dark? a show that I
still cannot believe anyone thought was acceptable
for young kids. So today, I went through.
I wasn't even brave enough to go through YouTube
clips of the scariest episodes. I just had
to find lists, and even the gifs kind of scared
me. So there's the one that, I don't like
clowns. Everyone's like, "oh, I'm afraid of
clowns." I think that's probably just universal.
I think we're all scared of clowns. They're
creepy. But there's multiple episodes involving
clowns. There's one where a kid seals a clown's
nose, and he's haunted by the clown after
that, which, I guess, teaches kids the valuable
lesson of don't steal from clowns, specifically,
which I just don't think is super applicable
in everyday life. Like, stealing's fine, but
clown nose, that's crossing the line.
Don't steal anything from a clown, especially
its nose.
Right. And then, there's one like, "The Grimace"?
It has the word grimace in it, and it's this
creepy. It's a comic book villain that comes
to life, but there's no superhero to stop
it. But the one that, I think, stuck with
me the most is where a young girl agrees to
spend the night in a haunted house, and there's
a requisite little girl ghost in there. And
she writes all over the walls, and she was
deaf, and she died of starvation. It's so
dark. It is so unrelentingly dark. And you're
supposed to believe there's a bunch of 12-year-old,
I think, Canadian kids sitting around a campfire
being like, "And then, she died." Like, what?
No. No, that show is-
They're all like, "What's the story all aboot,
eh?"
Right. Exactly. "Ooh, sorry for scaring you."
We just lost all our Canadian viewers.
It's just a joke. Canadians are better than
Americans. It's just a joke. We all know it's
true.
Yeah. You're above us because you're better
than us, that's why. Geographically, it's
on purpose.
I swear to God, it's all from insecurities
because we are the worst. Anyway, go on.
Brian and Nina are having a good time, but,
In my eyes, we're all equal.
Okay. Thanks for clearing that up. But yeah,
I remember I would be watching Nickelodeon
when this was on, when it aired, in real time,
and I would get up and walk out of the room
the second I heard. The opening credits had
like a creaking door as the very first noise.
And I would hear that, and I would just leave.
I wouldn't even turn the TV off. I don't know
why that wasn't my first instinct, but I'm
guessing I maybe just left the house just
to be like, "I can't even be-"
You're not even going to change the channel.
No, I was like, "I can't even be in the presence
of this."
"I'm out of here." Knowing that it's even
being broadcast, is too much for you. You
can't even watch TV-
Yeah, the fact that it's on television is
just ruining, yeah. You asked me what scarred
me for life, and I think I've delivered. Yeah,
Are You Afraid of the Dark? cool concept,
great idea. But it's really, really scary.
It's still scary. I'm 30, and I'm still scared
of it, so it did its job way too well, and
I don't understand who it was for, other than
kids without any anxiety who loved being scared
out of their minds. Not me. That's not me.
Some kids like that. That's why horror movies
are a thing.
Yeah. Yeah. No, thank you. Yeah. Thanks, I
hate it.
Okay, Are You Afraid of the Dark? is a good
pick. You know what else was pretty scary
from that same era? Roundhouse. Remember Roundhouse?
What are we talking about there, Brian?
So this gives you some insight into my age.
I remember when Are You Afraid of the Dark?
premiered on Snick, Saturday Nick.
Oh, I remember Snick.
It was only a nickel.
The first slate of programming was Are You
Afraid of the Dark?, Secret World of Alex
Mack, Rim and Stimpy, and a show called Roundhouse.
So I watched Alex Mack, and Are you Afraid.
Well, I didn't watch Are You Afraid of the
Dark?, but I don't remember Roundhouse at
all.
Roundhouse was a bunch of theater kids doing
long-form sketches, musical sketches, and
dances.
So was it like a predecessor to All That?
It's difficult to describe. I've gotten so
far off-topic that I'm just going to stop
talking about it. All I will say is that one
recurring character is a guy in a motorized
recliner. There's probably some fun visuals
going on right here. This part may all get
cut out because this is stupid. This is the
ramblings of an old, tired man. We'll look
up Roundhouse later. Did it scar me for life?
No. Do I remember it when no one else does?
Yes. Sorry.
That was my question. I wanted to know why
it was scary. Yeah.
It was just very weird. It was very odd. Roundhouse,
look at up.
Only on Snick.
Only on Snick. Saturday Nick, Snick.
I remember Snick. I'm not that young.
This was original Snick, one of the originals,
I don't think anybody remembers. I think this
is you compartmentalizing your weird childhood,
and maybe-
Is this a Mandela effect?
This is is part one of "Brian remembers things
that no one else has ever even heard of."
So just get ready to wait for-
Wait for part two.
Grew up in a theater troop, and there were
people practicing in your living room every
night. And you were like, "This is a great
TV show." Because then-
And one of them was named True, and she could
speak to the dead.
Tom, what are the kids' franchises that scarred
you for life?
Okay. First up, speaking to, Are You Afraid
of the Dark? Was it that, or was it Goosebumps
that had the purple slime guy? Do you guys
remember that? There was something-
It might've been Goosebumps.
I think it was Goosebumps. He didn't live
in a pool, did he? Because that was Are You
Afraid of the Dark? There were two separate
episodes set in school pools.
Are you thinking of the tar monster that killed
Tasha Yar on Star Trek: The Next Generation?
How does it always come back to Star Trek
with your people?
No, man, I'm not talking about the weird theater
troupe that you grew up in.
I think it was Goosebumps, Tom. But if I'm
wrong, it will probably say so at the bottom
of the screen.
It doesn't matter. I don't know if any of
this. It doesn't matter. What matters is Animorphs.
Do you guys remember Animorphs?
Yes.
Oh my God, yeah.
Remarkable. Okay, so they made a TV show out
of it. It was a series of kids books from
the Nineties that were written by a sociopath
named K. A. Applegate. They did a TV show
with one of the cats, the guy that played
Iceman in the X-Men movies.
That's right.
He's an identical twin. It could have been
him or his brother.
Ashmore? Shawn Ashmore?
Shawn Ashmore. Yeah.
Pretty sure that's his name. He's in a boy's-
He was in a lot of Disney Channel Original
Movies too. Like, a lot of Disney Channel
Original Movies.
I think you're absolutely right. Yeah. They
made a Nickelodeon live-action show out of
it. It was relatively bloodless. But if you
read the books, they were debilitatingly traumatizing.
So the idea was that there were these kids
who were basically giving field reports on
a war that they were fighting in secret in
the form of these books. They wouldn't tell
you like their full identities because this
is all really happening, and you're in a lot
of trouble, and anyone around you could be
an alien slug that had taken over your loved
one's brains, and they were out to get you.
What? That was the premise of Animorphs?
Yeah. Those were the bad guys. They were called
the Yeerks. And they were like little, tiny
slug monsters.
I feel like I didn't get any of that from
the TV show.
I know. So then, you got these five kids,
and they get alien super powers to turn into
whatever animal they can get their hands on.
Whatever they can get their mitts on, they
can turn into. And part of the process is
that. Number one, they could only stay an
animal for a couple of hours, or else they
would get stuck that way forever. And the
other thing was when they turned back into
people, they would heal anything that happened
to them. they could go through grievous injuries,
and they would come out the other end, just
find that. They would turn back into humans.
They'd be okay. But that meant that these
kids were getting like limbs blown off of
themselves, or their guts are just pouring
out all over the concrete.
They're 12. There were like 50 of these books,
And I loved them when I was a kid. They were
incredible to me.
That makes sense.
Just it's all this like body horror, terror,
psychological warfare too. The main character's
big brother is secretly an alien, and he's
like, "Do I kill my brother? I don't know
what to do." In the first book, one of the
kids get stuck as a bird, and then he's just
a bird for like the next 20 books. His family
just assumes that he's gone, nobody really
asks any questions. This kid is just stuck
as a bird with telepathy.
That doesn't seem like the worst thing.
When they turn into these animals, do their
lifespans change? Because I feel like what,
if you turn into an animal that has like a
fraction of the lifespan of a human being?
Oh, see, that's the thing. You got to turn
back within a couple hours, or else you get
stuck, so the lifespan thing, that doesn't
really come into play.
No, but what if you get stuck?
Now, see, that's a great. So like 30 books
in, they do the whole like evil Hulk, or like
when Sam Beckett ran into like the evil leapers
towards the end of Quantum Leap, they got
a bad Animorph. Another kid joined them, and
he turned out to be just a real piece of work.
So their solution to this kid who was ruining
all their lives was to trick him into turning
into a rat, and then they trapped him on an
island underground so that he couldn't turn
back into a person. This is bonkers. Yeah,
so they got this-
Who's the real villain now?
Yeah, right? So here's the other thing. So,
when they turn into animals, they can all
talk to each other through telepathy. That's
how they communicate. So what you wind up
with is this like 12-year-old kid who was
a brat, stuck as a rodent, living out on an
island, and then at the end of the book, they
just mentioned that there's urban legends
about, if you drive a boat past this island,
you'll just hear screaming in your head because
there's, Ugh.
I'm filming this at night, and I am not going
to sleep.
No, it's bananas. It's so bad. They go back
to the kid eventually. Like I said, there's
like 50 books in the series. I didn't read
all of them. You kind of age out of the animal
fight books with-
Or, you get too traumatized and you just move
on.
Yeah, you just can't read anymore because
your brain is-
And that's why you don't trust birds, right?
Moral of the story, I don't trust birds.
I don't trust birds either. They're shady.
Why are they always in groups? What are they
planning? I don't like them.
I would love to do another episode called,
"Why We Shouldn't Trust Birds."
I also don't trust birds.
No more pop culture. Just for 20 minutes,
let's just have a round table-
Just a Mickey Rooney-style video about why
we don't- or Andy Rooney, sorry. Also, Mickey
Rooney.
Andy Rooney, Mickey Rooney.
No, both of them. Let's do a Mickey Rooney-style,
"Hey, Everybody. I seen a pigeon the other
day, and I hated him. Oh, you know I'd get
him." I would love that.
I mean that, yeah. I meant that one.
I have two. The first one I have, everybody
knows about. The Violet Beauregard scene from
Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory.
Just that scene?
Fantastic.
That scene. I was shopping with my mom at
Kids 'R' Us. For those who don't recall, Kids
'R' Us was Toys 'R' Us' kids' clothes store.
And one of the few things that they had there
to make it seem more fun because you weren't
buying toys, you were just buying clothes,
was they had a video screen set up that all
the kids who were there with their moms were
like picking out their like sweatpants or
whatever, could watch for a few minutes before
that they'd go to the fitting room. So I remember
they had Willy Wonka and the Chocolate Factory
on, and this scene is playing, of this girl's
face turning purple, and then she starts to
blow up, and they're like, "You're going to
explode." I don't remember how old I was.
I had to been like five or six years old.
It ruined me. It ruined my brain. Terrified.
It's like, to this day, that scene gives me
the chills. I do not like to think about it.
Well, to be fair, that that whole movie is
really frightening. Like the Augustus Gloop
scene is horrifying. The ride down the river
is straight out of Apocalypse Now. I would
not be surprised if Scorsese stepped in and
directed that scene, and Martin sheen's playing
an Oompa Loompa in the back. A lot of that
movie is really, really scary. So yeah, I
support this choice.
I was not on board with a Willy Wonka reboot
until just now when you gave us a world where
Martin Sheen plays every Oompa Loompa.
Maybe he plays all of them.
I want to - Martin Sheen to do that. I almost
said Martin Short, and that would work too.
That would work better, yeah.
Too well.
Okay. So that's one. That's the obvious one.
But the one I wanted to show you guys, I have
a video clip that I'm popping in here. So
please boot this up.
I'm so anxious.
Start it up. This was a show from the Eighties
called Spartakus and the Sun Beneath the Sea.
This was on Nickelodeon in the Eighties. It
was a French animated cartoon that they dubbed
into English. I'm going to read you the introductory
monologue that they speak over the introductory
animation. These are the first words that
you hear when watching this children's show.
"Ever since the time of the great cataclysm,
the Arkadians have lived deep in the center
of the Earth. They believe they were the only
survivors of this great devastation. Their
civilization thrived under the power of their
sun, the Tehra, until it began to fail. In
desperation, the children of Arkadia broke
the law and entered the forbidden archives,
searching for a solution. What they discovered
gave them hope. Anxiously, they used their
special powers and created a messenger to
the people above. They named her Arkana."
What's going on here, Brian?
This is a show I watched as a child.
No, I'm watching the clip that you sent us.
I don't mind saying I would have accused you
of making this up if you haven't - Did you
animate this?
Yeah, if you had not shown me this clip. Did
you draw this last night?
I wish.
It says it was uploaded at 6:00 AM, and it
has two views.
So this is a show. I watched this show as
a kid.
Also, that's not true. Disclaimer, that's
not true.
I watched the show as a kid. I don't remember
understanding it. It's just some weird post-apocalyptic
adventure underground with weird fantasy robot
dinosaur, I don't know.
It feels like the matrix, but for kids.
It's disturbing to witness. It makes no sense.
I just sent you another clip. There were these
two little armadillo guys named Bic and Bac,
and they did a dance.
You know, I was noticing them, and I was wondering
if they did -
They do.
Yeah, I have questions about Bic and- Oh,
God.
So there's your dance. There's the dance.
And there's a whole song, which we're not
going to play here. But I encourage everyone
watching this to look up Bic and Bac from
Spartakus and the Sun Beneath the Sea. You'll
see two creepy- Yeah.
It looks He-Man if it was made by one of those
crappy companies that did the Bible cartoons,
from when you were a kid.
Yeah.
This looks like the world's worst acid trip,
like a kind that you never want to have.
So there was a period of time, hard to believe
now, but there was a period of time where
you were a child, and then there wasn't an
internet. So you just remembered things from
your childhood, but couldn't confirm or deny
their existence. So for the longest time,
I thought maybe I dreamed this show because
it's so weird and strange and very disturbing.
It's not necessarily intentionally disturbing.
It's like a fun adventure for kids, where
these two kids from the surface are drawn
into this strange fantasy adventure under
the Earth, but it's clearly made by people
with diseased brains, so I don't know.
The French.
Yes, the French.
There's my answer to the beginning of this
conversation. Everybody's equal, except the
French. I was waiting for a punchline. So
I had that exact same thing, but it was with
a cartoon special from the late Eighties or
early Nineties called The Cartoon All-Stars.
Oh, oh, is this where they all told the kid
not to smoke pot?
Yeah, don't smoke that pot because it's full
of the Tim Curry tar monster from FernGully.
What?
Nina, are you familiar with this?
No, someone educate me.
In the very early Nineties, late Eighties,
early Nineties, all of the cartoons of the
day teamed up to tell one kid not to smoke
that weed.
Wow.
It was one of the last moves that the Bush
administration did, was they put together
this video of-
The first one.
Maybe it was the Reagan administration, I
can't remember.
The Ninja Turtles were there. I'm pretty sure
it was Bush. Bush one.
That sounds like- Oh, I was going to say it
sounds like a Nancy doing.
It was Ninja Turtles, Slimer from Ghostbusters.
I remember that the President was at the beginning,
and he opens the whole thing up by saying,
"Hey kids, I just wanted to remind you, don't
trust -
I think it's Barbara Bush. I thought it was
Barbara Bush.
I think you're right. But it does sound like
a Reagan thing. And yeah, no, you're right.
So, Slimer's there telling people not to do
drugs, which is hilarious.
Because he's based on Jim Belushi. John Belushi,
excuse me. John Belushi.
Yeah, because he came out of the minds of
all of these old SNL, Bugs Bunny's there.
Let's see, Alf.
Bugs bunny's there. I think Alvin and the
Chipmunks might be? Alf is definitely there.
Alvin and the Chipmunks were absolutely there.
Winnie the Pooh shows up to say, "Don't smoke
crack." It is. It's incredible. It's like
20 minutes long. There's like 80 different-
Does Arsenio Hall show up, or did I make that
part up? Is there a cartoon Iron Man maybe?
I don't know. I really don't know.
Tom, I have a creepy one that- No, the kind
of like, I had just also had to make sure
it was real. Are you guys familiar with Boobahs?
No.
Oh boy. I'm sending a photo.
Boobahs.
Not at work.
They're really creepy. And it was, I think,
banned in a few countries for being too scary.
Oh my God. Hold the phone.
Oh, I remember this. Did they lay eggs?
I think so?
In your brain?
But they would dance around, and they'd go
like "Ah!" It was really, really scary. And
there's a website where you can like play
games related to Boobahs that are equally
as frightening, that involve, It'll just have
people, stock photos of actual humans- dying
in the mini games. Anyway, the show was actually
banned for being too creepy. It was banned.
I'm fine with that.
Yeah. Yeah. If you want to horrify yourself,
just spend a while on the internet looking
up Boobahs, and you'll hate your life.
I got to say, I want to make entertainment
for kids because this sounds like a great
scam. You can do anything. No one's watching.
You can do literally anything.
You can, right? Especially now.
Yeah.
The internet is just this vacuum that is never
going to be filled. And nobody's ever going
to check on all of it. No, I think it's a
brilliant idea. You remember the Casper movie
from the Nineties, where they like, "Yeah,
I'm a dead kid. I froze to death."?
That's right.
Yeah.
That's like a 10 minute scene where that kid
just explains that mortality is always looming.
We're Devon Sawa.
Yeah. Remember Hocus Pocus, when they turn
a kid into a cat for like his whole life?
And then, he goes to heaven at the end.
Yeah. I'm sorry. We all love Hocus Pocus,
but that's objectively really messed up.
All right. Well, I think we've decided that
we're all going to go into children's television
soon, and make our-
Yeah, and create something even more horrifying.
make our nightmares their reality. Thanks
for watching. Please hit like and subscribe,
so you don't miss a single episode.